hasta ahora solamente hemos
parametrizado una curva con un solo
parámetro lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es parametrizar una superficie en
tres dimensiones usando dos parámetros y
vamos a empezar con un ejemplo que es un
toro
a un toro o más conocido como la forma
de una dona perfecto y sabemos a qué se
parece una verdad voy a dibujarla en un
color espero poner un color apropiado
para las zonas como verde una dones como
esta verdad tiene un hueco en el centro
y tal vez en el otro lado lo podemos
dibujar de esta forma para que más o
menos parezca un add-on es más vamos a
sombrear la así como se ve muy bien así
se ve la don entonces como lo
construimos usando dos parámetros lo que
queremos hacer es que podamos
visualizarla como si dibujara mos unos
ejes aquí déjenme déjenme de dibujo los
ejes supongamos que tengo el eje z que
va de arriba a abajo y que está dibujado
justo
es más incluso lo va a pintar inclinado
que pasa justo en el centro de la dona
si seguimos así bueno esto va a ser como
una especie de ejercicios de dibujo más
bien
entonces este es mi eje z y podemos
imaginar que el eje z va desde hasta
arriba hasta abajo y lo que sale de este
lado será el eje x
correcto y lo que salga de este otro
lado será el eje y sale de esta manera y
la razón por la cual lo dibujé de esta
forma es para que imagines en la sección
de cruce en donde se encuentra la dona y
apreciar la más fácilmente así que los
ejes x z digamos
en el plano que me define los ejes x y z
cortan en una sección circular de esta
forma y este sería la forma del círculo
bueno trazar un círculo como esto es
simplemente hacer la intersección de ese
eje con el toro ahora vamos a rastrear
otro círculo que se obtiene de
interceptar el plano ez con el toro
verdad y se ve de la misma forma así que
vamos a pensar que es un manojo de
círculos rotando alrededor del eje z si
lo piensas de esta forma nos daremos muy
buena intuición de la forma de
parametrizar esta cosa así que vamos a
hacerlo de esta forma vamos a empezar
solo con el eje y con el eje z por este
lado y vamos a pintar de este otro lado
oops perdón vamos a pintar el eje y muy
bien entonces lo que estoy viendo es
este círculo que le estoy colocando un
centro en azul ok y el centro se sitúa
sobre el eje y aquí a lo mejor el dibujo
no es muy claro pero bueno esa es la
idea de lo que estoy haciendo y digamos
que hay una distancia ve al centro es
decir al eje
la verdad al centro del toro la
distancia que habrá es ve y esta
distancia también aplica para todos los
círculos que se encuentran en el toro
muy bien ahora voy a pintar la parte
digamos superior del toro digamos que lo
estamos viendo desde una perspectiva
desde arriba sale entonces sólo se ve
algo así como como una especie de anillo
el eje z va a ser como como si estuviera
saliendo de la pantalla verdad entonces
tenemos aquí lo es
los ejes xy
ok entonces estoy volando y estoy viendo
desde arriba
midón y se verá de esta forma si te
imaginas la sección transversal este
círculo va a corresponder a una línea
verdad este círculo sólo corresponde a
una línea por ejemplo que está en el eje
y y quedaría solo como eso y la
distancia ve simplemente es la distancia
en esta perspectiva al punto medio del
segmento déjenme pintarlo con otro con
el mismo color perdón el moralito esta
sería nuestra distancia ve la distancia
al centro de los círculos que aquí desde
esta perspectiva se ven simplemente como
líneas va a ser ve esto me debe todo
esto me debe desde el centro del toro
hasta el centro del círculo y eso es lo
que definimos como la distancia vez así
que en esta distancia en el plano
detalle ahí pintamos nuestro ve y
podemos imaginar que las secciones
tienen un radio de longitud
para estos círculos la longitud que
pintamos de amarillo es d
2 la verdad es decir ese es el diámetro
el radio es de a
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es tener
dos parámetros uno es el ángulo que hace
el radio de la sección con el plano xy y
el otro bueno lo que podemos imaginar es
que de aquí sale el el eje x verdad en
amarillo se pueden imaginar que sale de
aquí
este es el plano xy y para un parámetro
va a ser el ángulo entre nuestro radio y
el plano xy y vamos a llamar ese ángulo
o ese parámetro y vamos a llamar digamos
que es ese y así ese va entre 0 y 2 pi
y como ese va entre 0 y 2 y cuando vale
0 sólo va a ser este puntito que coloque
aquí y luego recorriendo lo todo 2 pi
estoy haciendo el círculo que se ve como
ese ahora sólo tenemos un parámetro lo
que queremos hacer es girar alrededor
del eje z para obtener todo el toro
verdad es decir vamos a barrer lo vamos
a barrer lo alrededor del eje z y vamos
a definir otro parámetro digamos a este
parámetro le voy a poner t déjenme
déjenme hacer otra vista superior para
no hacer mucho alboroto como pueden ver
todo es una cuestión de visualización
así que vamos a decir que aquí están mis
ejes xy y vamos a comenzar con una
distancia ve al eje z verdad sobre el
eje y es decir estamos trabajando en el
plano receta el plano es digamos el eje
z es el que podría estar apareciendo
fuera de la pantalla y bueno cuando ese
es igual a cero radiales vamos a estar
precisamente aquí
exactamente a una distancia
del punto y vamos a rodear todo este
camino hasta este punto vamos vamos a
ver este diámetro ahora para hacer la
dona lo que queremos es girar alrededor
del eje z vamos a girar alrededor del
eje z que está mirando hacia arriba
hacia nosotros digamos y que está
saliendo desde de la pantalla ahora para
rotar lo vamos a dibujar un círculo
alrededor del eje z
y para ello vamos a definir un parámetro
que nos dice cómo nos hemos puesto a
girar cuánto hemos girado es decir
cuánto hemos rotado alrededor del eje
entonces en algún momento vamos a estar
aquí y lo haríamos digamos en un radio
igual a b
entonces estos estos que estamos
pintando en este momento habrán girado
digamos una digamos algunos radiales
vamos a llamarle a este parámetro
este parámetro vamos a llamarle t y
también va a variar t entre 0 y 2 pi
que está entre 0 y 2 pi y quiero dejar
esto muy claro vamos a llamar realmente
el dominio que le estamos asignando de
de nuestra superficie por lo que
entendemos entenderemos completamente la
superficie en un dominio en donde el
aceite se permiten estar entre 0 y 2 pib
perfecto vamos a tener una función de
valores vectoriales así que vamos a
pintar digamos ahora el espacio de los
parámetros vamos a pintar aquí te que
recordemos que es los radiales que
estamos midiendo en este último ejemplo
y al eje de abajo vamos a llamar el eje
s y esto va a ayudar a a ver oa
simplificar las cosas un poco entonces
cuando s es igual a 0 lo que vamos a
estar variando es cs entre 0 y 2 pi
así que ese permite estar en estos
valores digamos aquí está pi
aquí está y medios y aquí va a estar
3 y medios y hacemos lo mismo con el eje
que vamos a ir de 0 a 2
aquí está de 0 a 2 pi y lo que quiero
realmente es visualizar la
parametrización que creo que va a ser
algo muy sencillo así que aquí va a
estar y aquí está y medios aquí va a
estar tres medios tres medios
y vamos a pensar en lo que parece cuando
tenemos algunos de los parámetros
constantes digamos que ese es 0 entonces
cuando ese es cero tenemos todos estos
posibles valores para t que van entre 0
y 2 pi
así si lo piensas debe ser una curva en
tres dimensiones verdad estamos dejando
fija s por lo tanto nuestra
parametrización sólo varía en un
parámetro
que entonces nos representará una curva
así que si pintamos aquí los ejes x el
eje i y luego el eje z
ok el eje zeta ok un poquito derecho
vamos a hacerlo más grande mejor creo
que ayudará a todos nosotros a
visualizarlo así que pintemos más grande
el eje x luego vamos a pintar más grande
el eje y y finalmente el eje z y sube de
esta forma muy bien ahora recuerdo
cuando s es igual a cero ok quién era
ese vamos a retomarlo ese era el ángulo
entre este radio y el plano xy así que
no hemos girado alrededor de esto en lo
absoluto
si ese es cero entonces ahora vamos a
colocar el centro el centro del círculo
que si recuerdan estaba a una distancia
b y además tenemos un radio que me idea
así que este segundo punto va a ser de
masa esto es b y luego le sumamos a
ahora vamos a rotar t que era cuánto
habíamos girado alrededor del eje z por
lo tanto esta línea t que dibujamos en
el espacio de los parámetros en nuestro
dominio etc
además pearl o corresponde a una curva
que es esencialmente el borde de una
circunferencia verdad es un borde de la
rosquilla de la dona y para hacer mejor
esto déjenme
pintar los ejes también en su dominio
tanto negativo ya había pintado los
positivos los positivos perdón vamos a
dibujar también los negativos así es
entonces para esta línea nuestro plano
en el plano ts esto representa
a una circunferencia entonces aumentamos
los radiales de 0 a 2 pi y entonces es
perdón
aquí estamos dibujando hasta pi y luego
damos otro pri medios y finalmente damos
toda la vuelta que corresponde a dos
peak girando alrededor del eje z como
nos indica el parámetro t y manteniendo
a ese constante ahora vamos a hacer otro
punto vamos a decir digamos cuando s es
igual a pi ok entonces vi
recordemos que 180 grados entonces en
este dibujito el ángulo s corresponde a
este punto de acá y vamos a mantenerlo
constante en ese igual aquí vamos a
tomar el interior de los anillos ya
verán porque cuando s es igual a pi en
nuestro espacio ese combate es fijar eso
y ahora nos fijamos en este punto de por
acá
si el centro es ve el punto en amarillo
que pinte corresponde a ve - a ahora
aquí en el espacio st
dejamos fijo s en pi y corresponde a una
línea ahora esta línea corresponderá a
una circunferencia parametrizado
en el espacio tridimensional a algo así
verdad fue mi mejor intento al
introducirlo y así podemos hacerlo
múltiples veces podríamos hacerlo
incluso con distintos colores por
ejemplo cuando s es igual a pie entre 2
es decir tenemos 90 grados correcto y a
continuación lo que tendríamos es
digamos la tapa superior o el círculo
superior de nuestra dona entonces
digamos que podríamos empezar por aquí
en este puntito amarillo y cuando ese es
y medios lo que vamos a variar este
entre cero y dos pick up's tengo muchos
problemas para pintar líneas rectas así
que al variar te lo que tendríamos es la
parte superior de estos círculos digamos
estas secciones circulares y lo que nos
va a dar variando todo t es este círculo
superior que va a ser algo así más o
menos en la parte superior de nuestros
anillos si estaba exacto si quería ser
sólo la parte inferior de la dona pues
simplemente tomaré la parte donde s es
igual a 3 y medios 3 y medios tomamos en
esta línea y entonces corresponde al
círculo inferior justo ahí
ok a lo mejor no se alcanza a ver todo
si esto fuera transparente bueno se
podría localizar muy bien y al variar te
tendremos este círculo sé que el gráfico
se está volviendo un poco confuso espero
que cache muy bien de la idea y cuando
ese es igual a 2 y tendremos de nuevo
los círculos que estamos pintando verdad
cuando s es igual a 2 pi tendremos el
mismo círculo que cuando s era igual a 0
variando t ahora vamos a hacer lo
contario con lo contrario perdón qué
sucede si mantenemos de igual a cero
tengamos este igual a 0 muy bien
entonces de igual a cero significa que
no hemos girado alrededor del eje z así
que si te es igual a 0 y es lo empezamos
a mover entonces tendremos una de las
secciones transversales verdad aquí
estamos pintando ese entre 0 y pi medios
ahora seguimos pintando entre 0 perdón
entre pi medios y pitt muy bien sumamos
otro pi medios aquí estamos ya en la
parte baja y terminamos el camino hasta
2 pi esta línea este círculo corresponde
en el espacio de los parámetros a cuando
te es igual a cero perfecto por ejemplo
ahora cuando te es igual la vamos a
hacer de un color diferente cuando te es
igual a pi medios
dejamos fijo te iguala pi medios
entonces hemos dado una vuelta alrededor
del eje z en un ángulo de medios así que
andaremos en esta circunferencia de por
acá cuando vayamos s esta línea en los
parámetros corresponde al círculo azul y
lo podríamos seguir haciendo para cuando
éste es igual a ti tendremos este mismo
camino pero en otra posición digamos
sería en este lado verdad habiéndole
dado media vuelta al eje zeta
muy bien variando todo esto entonces
estaríamos rellenando toda la zona
verdad claro ahora este color digamos
morado es cuando te es igual a tres y
medios
estaríamos justo sobre el eje x verdad
en el eje x y de hecho es en el plano x
zeta aumentamos ese y nos da otro
circulito igual a los anteriores y por
supuesto cuando llegue a t igualados pi
ya habré recorrido todos los círculos y
empezamos nuevamente así que podemos
oscurecer un poquito más para que se vea
que es lo que estamos haciendo hasta
ahorita no hemos hecho matemáticas
realmente solo hemos hecho visualización
de qué es lo que queremos en un sentido
de parametrizar con dos parámetros
nuestra superficie y sólo para tener una
ligera idea de lo que estas áreas
en el espacio se te corresponden en la
superficie en lo que supongo que se
podría decir en el espacio de tres
dimensiones estapé que este pequeño
cuadro de aquí que está acotado digamos
por ese entre medios
y ese está perdón es está entre 0 y pi
medios y t también entre 0 y pi medios
entonces a qué corresponde estamos
moviéndonos en s / pyme dios' 0 y pi
medios que es esta parte del toro vamos
a moverlo así es esta sección verdad
porque también te lo estamos variando
entre 0 y pi medios es decir se está
viendo desde la parte digamos superior
más o menos se vería de esta forma
verdad entonces puedes imaginarte que
hemos trazado esta parte del área de de
la superficie
matemáticamente no he demostrado nada
pero bueno sólo quiero que lo visualicen
por ahora ahora creo que hemos hecho una
muy buena perspectiva de lo que es
parametrizar realmente estaremos listos
para parametrizar formalmente esta
superficie vamos a tomar ese que es
girar
alrededor o más bien separarnos del
plano x y te va a ser girar alrededor
del eje z y así vamos a terminar como
parametrizar esta superficie ambos
parámetros estarán entre 0 y 2 pi y lo
convertiremos en una superficie en tres
dimensiones muy bien vamos a tener una
posición vectorial y lo haremos en el
siguiente vídeo